Parfois je me demande, dis-je, notre maison est
Où est notre rue, où suis-je, je le jure
Je ne peux même plus penser au pays
Je ne sais pas ce qui va se passer
[Musique]
Avant, c'était comme ça, comme un festival
Il se mettrait dans l'ambiance, alors quelque chose lui arriverait
Alors il a dit que c'était comme un match
C'était le destin, nous gagnerons, ce n'est rien
nous, nos vies, nous sommes échappés
J'aurais aimé que ces événements ne soient pas une élection
J'apprécierais de ne pas avoir le choix
Nous avons donc déjà vécu des choses comme ça
Alors, des élections étaient-elles nécessaires ?
Les citoyens ne s'inquiètent pas des élections.
Quelle est la situation du citoyen âgé ?
Citoyen, où vais-je vivre, où vais-je vivre ?
Je vais m'asseoir pour voir où je vais manger.
Nos électeurs l'ont pris et nos spécialistes du marketing sont partis
Notre commerçant du soir s'est dispersé et est parti
Les morts deviennent l'enfer, Viranşehir
Que puis-je dire? Nous sommes vraiment désolés.
Croyez-moi, nous sommes touchés
[Musique]
Je ne veux pas d'argent, je ne veux rien
Je n'en veux pas, ce que je veux, ce sont mes cheveux.
Une maison dans laquelle le mettre, sachant que
Ils voient que personne ne veut ça de nous
Il n’a aucun droit, laissez-les d’abord trouver une solution.
Laissez-les le trouver et demandez-le aux gens.
[Musique]